ma dove siamo
il museo ovviamente eccoci giunti nel
container della m
make fare appunto guardi guardi queste
fotografie e in questi stabilimenti che
avviene la produzione in italia i luoghi
della fatica fisica dei turni fatta di
concentrazione di rispetto delle regole
precise ma anche di passione e di
esperienza
una fatica grande che ripaga con i
risultati vivere e respirare
noi siamo abituati a pensare l'uomo che
progetta e trasforma la realtà che lo
circonda
ma se osserviamo il respiro capiamo che
l'uomo può essere colui che vuole
progetto e trasforma solo a condizione
che accetti che nella natura esista
qualcosa di indipendente da noi e di cui
non possiamo fare a meno
ecco perché l'immagine sulla confezione
una figura umana fatta di area
circondata di aria a sottolineare lo
scambio continuo che avviene tra l'uomo
e l'ambiente al centro di tutto c'è la
persona della quale zambon deve
occuparsi quando si prende cura della
sua salute
una responsabilità un impegno verso
l'essere umano
bene ora si è concluso il nostro viaggio
grazie
io credo che sia proprio grazie a questo
soffio ispiratore
se mi permette di essere qui oggi tra di
voi perché l'impresa è una realtà viva e
quello che come imprenditori devi
garantirgli è quello ossigeno per
continuare a riproporre un soffio
ispiratore che è un fatto profondo di
spirito no diceva e allora cosa c'entra
una fabbrica no il luogo della fatica
dove ci si logora dove ci sono anche dei
turni faticosi con la bellezza
io credo che la bellezza possa aiutarci
a cambiare la prospettiva della fabbrica
perché può essere un linguaggio nuovo e
quello che abbiamo fatto nella fabbrica
di vicenza iniziato nel 2009 inaugurata
nel 2013
per fortuna per necessità di aumentare
le produzioni abbiamo ripensato il luogo
del fare
il simbolo del progetto concreto di dove
si fanno le compresse che è difficile
spiegare a qualcuno cosa c'è dentro una
compressa sono tutte uguali al limite
cambiano il colore ma quello di cui ci
siamo resi conto che valeva la pena in
un'era come questa valorizzarla e
ricambiare le proporzioni quindi e
riportandola al centro e facendo sì che
come potente strumento di comunicazione
la fabbrica attraverso la bellezza
potesse tornare ad essere attrattiva
parlo a voi giovani a voi che avete un
futuro che in qualche modo esclude in
quest epoca digitale il luoghi appunto
del manufatto in si chiama l'italia è un
paese che ha per fortuna il
manifatturiere molto importanti io credo
che ci sia una possibilità in più
nell'integrare queste due forze e che
possa arrivare un opportunità da questa
se riportiamo allora al centro una
fabbrica come simbolo di qualità della
salute quello che noi abbiamo chiesto a
questa fabbrica e di esprimere
attraverso la bellezza la qualità che
c'è dentro
non so se potete immaginare una persona
che sta poco bene che non sia in qualche
modo poco in forma
io credo che la bellezza anche di una
fabbrica diventi espressione di quanto è
sana quell'impresa al suo interno di
come rispetta le regole la transitate
zzà la cura con cui in qualche modo la
porti verso il futuro è espressione di
quella qualità che influenza tutta
l'azienda e tutte le funzioni quindi la
fabbrica non diventa più solo luogo di
produzione ma diventa luogo di
formazione per lo sviluppo delle
conoscenze queste sono dei ballatoi dove
la fabbrica si apre a medici farmacisti
ma anche a studenti di medicina ai primi
anni delle scuole per capire come si
crea un farmaco per toccare con mano la
qualità vedere coi propri occhi le
regole che vanno rispettate la
differenza che c'è tra progettare in
questo luogo si dovrebbe dire e poi
realizzare un farmaco tanto tempo e
tante risorse chiede quali sono però gli
step essenziali per arrivare alla fine
di questo cammino
quello che però non può escludere in
un'impresa che io chiamo comunità di
ripresa per che lega le persone attorno
a un progetto comune che credono nelle
stesse cose è il luogo dove si deve
valorizzare il lato umano e quindi gli
spazi luoghi di lavoro diventano uno
spazio accogliente dove le persone hanno
voglia di stare dove i professionisti
coloro che possono dare un contributo
possono interagire anche nel luogo del
convivio questo è quello che noi
chiamiamo kitchen e open air
così come nei momenti informali ci sono
degli strumenti i banali calcio balilla
o il ping pong che ti aiutano a
condividere io credo una filosofia di
lavoro che è quella che migliora le
relazioni tra le persone crea dei legami
che vanno al di là delle autore di
lavoro anche perché spesso diventano più
di otto ore e riesce proprio ad
instaurare un clima positivo all'interno
di persone questo diventa generativo
come dice ragazzi e in un'azienda
dove evidentemente è un'azienda delle
conoscenze per dovere per settore in cui
opera l'innovazione continua a sfidarla
allora aiutare le persone a stare
insieme anche il modo informale le aiuta
in qualche modo a trovare delle
interazioni degli interessi comuni
attraverso quello che noi chiamiamo il
nostro ben vivere
guardiamo però insieme come è nata
questa idea di questa fabbrica qual è il
significato perché un nuovo progetto per
vicenza perché vicenza e dove zambon
nascere nel 1906 e dove si radica qui
sono le sue origini è anche il luogo
dove si sviluppo e dove comunque
mantiene salda i valori della propria
identità
in questa città che le ha offerto molto
e quindi dopo 100 anni appunto a 106
anni e ho sentito spontaneo il ritorno
in questa città e in particolare nello
stabilimento di vicenza che è diventato
il luogo di eccellenza come fabbrica
espressione di tecnologia ma soprattutto
espressione di qualità
come elena parliamo spesso del problema
di trasformare la ditta farmaceutica in
un'azienda che sappia dimostrare di più
anche il senso sociale e civile di
quello che realizza quindi non più una
fabbrica di medicine ma una fabbrica
della salute corrisponde a un impegno
specifico dell'azienda per curare e
rendere più consapevole alla
partecipazione di chi lavora in zambon
rispetto alla l'obiettivo finale
il nuovo edificio d'ingresso è un
edificio molto verticale rispetto alla
estensione piana dello stabilimento
lo stabilimento che a due piani serviti
da un'inter piano tutto tecnico un
grande volume che è una grande vetrina
che rende tutto lo stabilimento
riconoscibile dall'autostrada che gli
passa davanti e di realizzare un un
elemento di evidenza che caratterizza a
tutto l'impianto
sicuramente importante avere un luogo in
cui passare dei momenti conviviali
il fatto poi che si erga in mezzo a
questa d'arresto più basso piano da un
bell'effetto migliora il trascorrere
della giornata perché comunque si va a
lavoro però 6 spronato a fare del tuo
meglio e comunque sai che sei in un
ambiente positivo anche per la parte per
esempio solo per gli incontri formativi
avere degli ambienti più più moderni più
con questa firma michele lasci il segno
lasci il segno in una fabbrica che per
noi è molto importante perché è la
fabbrica con la quale diamo un segnale
forte della volontà di esprimere di
portare in giro per il mondo il senso
della qualità e la responsabilità del
fare salute per gli altri che implica
appunto qualità
no
beh michele credo che sia forse in
questo luogo un architetto un grande
architetto e un restauratore di bellezza
non siamo in fondo nella sua triennale
in qualche modo dove con noi è riuscito
a fare questo cammino in cui la salute
incontra l'arte di un design architetto
chiedendo a lui come design e come tutti
i designer sono io credo interpreti di
una modernità di un modo nuovo di
comunicare quello che però riguardato
non ha riguardato solo un cammino che
guardava il luogo del fare della
fabbrica ma ha riguardato una sfida più
grande è quello di accettare l'impresa
di unire l'arte alla salute
e allora con lui che abbiamo iniziato
questo cammino dove ci invitava
continuamente a trovare attraverso
l'immaginazione che l'arte sollecita con
occhi nuovi
un modo diverso di fare le cose rispetto
alle grandi multinazionali abbiamo la
consapevolezza di avere dimensioni
diverse ma abbiamo anche quell orgoglio
di appartenere a un italia che di
bellezza continua a parlarci basta
girare le nostre città ecco perché la
scelta di vicenza la città del palato in
fondo quindi questi occhi diversi
ci hanno permesso di rivisitare tutto
tutte le funzioni aziendali e quindi
anche il nostro packaging perché quello
che volevamo trasferire l'umanizzazione
non solo del modo con cui intendiamo e
interpretiamo la responsabilità che
abbiamo verso la salute delle persone ma
anche nelle forme con cui cerchiamo di
spiegarla qui vedete i bozzetti con cui
masahiko cubo un artista giapponese è
riuscito io credo l'arte orientale abbia
la capacità di sintesi estrema con quel
tratto che unico beh nel non più un
immagine ma l'avete visto anche nel
filmato una trama che si integra
fortemente guardando a una nuova
prospettiva che è quella un'ambizione
appunto sentendo forte questa
responsabilità quasi di orientare verso
una nuova architettura quello di creare
una città della salute e questo impatto
non solo su alcuni ma su tutti
i nostri prodotti dove abbiamo cercato
di rivisitarli badando più al sollievo
al beneficio che creano che non alla
patologia e alla malattia
quindi la medicina che diventi una
medicina della persona al centro la
persona a cui puoi comunicare con cui
poi dialogare per capire come prevenire
come pensare di migliorare la sua
qualità di vita spesso in quest'epoca
difficile
e qui arriva il secondo messaggio se
prima volevo darvi il senso di come la
bellezza per noi è stata di grande aiuto
per trasferire tutti questi concetti
io credo che ci sia un messaggio ancora
più profondo che in qualche modo si lega
a quello che abbiamo sentito prima ed è
l'estetica non solo come un linguaggio o
meglio l'immagine di ciò che hai dentro
di qualcosa di molto più profondo perché
diversamente è un'incoerenza di fondo
che non avrebbe significato anzi credo
che potrebbe portarti del male allora se
ci pensate bene parlando di bellezza
parliamo di estetica e dentro
all'estetica c'è una parola profonda che
si chiama etica i valori in cui crede le
cose che ti spingono a fare delle
imprese impossibili
ecco in questa parola est etica sta
tutto il senso di quello che un'impresa
al suo interno come comunità di persone
può trasferire all'esterno e deve
trasferire nell'impegno quotidiano che
ci mette del fare quindi sicuramente
l'espressione di una bellezza interiore
che in qualche modo non è
necessariamente esteriore esteriorità ma
è qualcosa che hai dentro che ti fa
trovare un energia anche nei momenti
difficili della vita per raggiungere no
e pensare di trasformare quelle
difficoltà anche in una forza e
un'energia che hai dentro e se accetti
di metterci cuore quella passione allora
raggiunge traguardi che non avresti mai
immaginato
chi ci ha aiutato in questo un altro
percorso per darvi il senso della
coerenza io credo che le imprese vadano
misurate per la loro coerenza nelle cose
che fanno conta il modo con cui fai le
cose quindi io credo questo gigante per
tutti noi dell'umanità che ci invita a
vedere la vera bellezza come stia nel
cuore e nella purezza del cuore
allora insieme a lui abbiamo cercato di
esplorare in questi anni il lato umano
di una comunità di impresa che crea dei
legami perché suo grande insegnamento è
stato e non fate io non faccio nessuna
distinzione tra etica e business però
che cosa vuol dire per un'impresa che
ogni giorno qualsiasi operazione
qualsiasi decisione deve domandarsi di
fondo quale conseguenza crea e allora
solo così riesce ad integrare
chiamandola nel nostro caso in presente
grave che integra etica business
i risultati aziendali non sono tutto ci
sono dei valori ci sono
come dire dei principi che ci guidano e
ci hanno guidato in questi anni in un
percorso attraverso il quale michele ci
ha aiutato a umanizzare anche i valori
queste queste questi grandi giganti ci
hanno sulle spalle loro ci siamo messi
per guardare lontano
e allora qui mi avvio la conclusione
quando uno di questi il madre teresa
come il simbolo della qualità che ci ha
aiutato a riflettere su questi temi ci
invita a guardare al bello perché la
bellezza può trasformare in ottimismo
anche progetti di bellezza in cui ogni
dettaglio è fondamentale questo è
l'ultimo piano della fabbrica dove ci
sono degli ulivi perché avevamo fatto un
viaggio in israele insieme e l'ulivo
l'abbiamo portato a casa abbiamo portato
in questo giardino degli ulivi dove
avviene la formazione dove avrete visto
quei collaboratori che parlavano unisce
quindi la bellezza della fabbrica
assurdi significato interiore questo è
lo sforzo che luoghi belli come lo pensi
solo che sono in tutti i luoghi in cui
siamo a milano come a vicenza perché
diventano video grazie ai contenuti che
li mette dentro grazie alla
partecipazione come voi fate oggi
insieme perché prenda spazio quel
dialogo di cui parlava francesco de
brabham aprendoci agli altri anche
immaginando che la ricerca possa essere
condivisa creando un campus della salute
un campus della ricerca alle porte di
milano dove ancora una volta bisogna
dedicare spazio alla bellezza a dei
luoghi dove avvengono delle cose come in
oxygen dove il territorio è
continuamente invitato e sollecitato a
pensare a che cosa significa
dirò questo patrimonio comune di tutti
in una struttura avveniristica che
sempre con michele abbiamo studiato
pensando alle nuove generazioni per
farle riflettere rispetto a questa
responsabilità che abbiamo verso anche
tutto il mondo e concludo con un
messaggio che non poteva che essere di
una scienziata che ha avuto ben due
nobel e che ci invita senz'altro a
guardare al progresso scientifico come
una necessità ma non può essere ridotto
a macchine ingranaggi ma l'umanità
lei crede e ci invita a pensare ha
bisogno di persone d'azione ma anche di
sognatori e allora quello che vi auguro
di essere dei sognatori di bellezza
perché la bellezza può trasformare il
mondo e può girare questo paese e nella
valorizzazione di quello che abbiamo e
che abbiamo la fortuna di avere grazie a
tutti